unruhe in der größten oppositionspartei
im bundestag die afg alternative für
deutschland sie ringt um die richtige
richtung anlass ist der parteiausschluss
des brandenburger fraktionschefs kalbitz
wegen seiner kontakte ins rechtsextreme
milieu und auch der sogenannte
umstrittene flügel um den thüringer bion
höckel wurde formal aufgelöst
an diesen entscheidungen gibt es aber
heftige kritik besonders aus den
ostdeutschen landesverbänden den
hochburgen der afd
wer bestimmt also in zukunft den kurs
der partei die er teilweise vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird und
deren umfragewerte gerade sinken
machtkampf in der fdp partei vor der
spaltung unser thema heute in der 15
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen
georg pastowski ist bei uns erst der
vorsitzende der fdp fraktion im berliner
abgeordnetenhaus schönen guten abend ich
begrüße maria fiedler sie ist politische
korrespondentin im hauptstadtbüro des
tagesspiegels und berichtet seit 2017
über die afd und zugeschaltet sind uns
werner patzelt er ist
politikwissenschaftler und er ist
mitglied der cdu hat auch am
wahlprogramm der cdu sachsen mit
geschrieben und er gehört zur werte
union das ist ein verein von cdu und csu
mitgliedern die die partei konservativer
ausrichten wollen und er hat auch vor
einigen jahren gutachten für die afg
geschrieben show guten abend der patient
nach dresden
und ich begrüße steffen kanitz er ist
politikwissenschaftler am hannah arendt
institut für totalitarismusforschung an
der tu dresden
er war sachverständiger im nsu
untersuchungsausschuss des bayerischen
landtags und auch gutachter im zweiten
npd verbotsverfahren vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht schönen guten
abend herr kreidet er passt es gibt
unruhe in der afd
da sind ist man sich nicht so ganz einig
steht diese partei vor der spaltung
nein das sehe ich nicht die partei steht
nicht vor der spaltung
bei so einer entscheidung die getroffen
worden ist ist es ganz normal dass
unruhe in eine partei kommt denn das ist
ja kein entschluss den man jeden tag
fast ich muss aber sagen der
bundesvorstand konnte eigentlich gar
nicht anders entscheiden
er hat auch richtig entschieden und ich
weiß dass man auf einer seriösen basis
entschieden hat aber ich sehe die partei
noch in unruhe aber auf gar keinen fall
was immer gesagt wird vor einer spaltung
warum war es richtig diese entscheidung
so zu treffen
andreas kalbitz auszuschließen ja wir
müssen natürlich schauen ob tatsächlich
2013 alle angaben gemacht worden sind
von den kallwitz die eigentlich
notwendig waren und wir haben ja die uhr
sitzung die ja notwendig ist um eine
partei zu gründen
wir haben die ersten mitgliedsanträge
und die mitglieder des bundesvorstandes
haben sich das genau angeschaut und dann
festgestellt dass er cannabis vor
mitgliedschaften verschwiegen hat auch
angaben die notwendig gewesen wären
verschwiegen hat und das bedeutet er hat
im prinzip damals nicht den mut zur
wahrheit gehabt und deshalb ist auch die
parteimitgliedschaft als nicht engagiert
und es ging um die mitgliedschaft des
vereins heimattreue einer rechtsextremen
organisation ja es geht auch um die
republikaner das ist auch nicht
angegeben worden es gibt dazu
mitgliederlisten wo eben nur drinsteht
dass er in der csu war und in der jungen
union aber nicht in diesen parteien
beziehungsweise auch in entsprechenden
organisationen und ich weiß dass die
mitglieder des bundesvorstandes
angeguckt haben das sind ja die sieben
von denen drei volljuristen sind eine
ist ein rechtspfleger haben sich ja sehr
genau angeschaut und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass diese entscheidung
auch hält weil ich glaube dass hier
nicht einfach in das knie gebrochen
worden ist sondern dass man das sehr
sehr gut gemacht
aber wie gesagt ist er seitdem gibt es
in große unruhe in der partei gab es
aber auch schon vorher wir haben ja auch
schon andere andere parteimitglieder
sind ja auch schon ausgetreten
frau fiedler wie beurteilen sie das was
da im moment passiert in der afg ist das
ein klarer richtungsstreit und wird man
wird die partei sich eben dann spalten
weil man dann irgendwo sehen muss in
welche richtung sie sich entwickelt also
erstmal muss man sagen dass es ein
ziemlich außergewöhnlicher vorgang ist
also so zerstritten wie die partei jetzt
war sie meines erachtens 2017 seit dem
austritt von frauke petry nicht mehr
und das hat natürlich ein enormes
sprengpotenzial und also man man hat das
auch gesehen wie also wie die partei bis
in die spitze hinein eigentlich
zerstritten ist da wurde ein mitglieder
schreiben versandt wo erneuten der eine
partei vorsitzende seine sicht der dinge
dargelegt hat und dann wurde in einem
anhang hat herr pofalla der co
parteivorsitzende seine sicht der dinge
dargelegt also quasi zwei botschaften in
einer mail
und das zeigt natürlich auch den
mitgliedern wie zerstritten
da die parteispitze ist und selbst wenn
es jetzt nicht zu einer abspaltung oder
zu einer spaltung der partei kommt muss
es doch irgendwie innerhalb zu einer
klärung kommen und da ist auch ein
showdown nicht unwahrscheinlich
herr patzelt wie würden sie es
beurteilen sie beobachten die afg ist
auch weit lange wie groß oder wie ernst
ist die krise die durch diesen streit
durch diesen ausschluss von calbe z
ausgelöst worden ist ja fdp steht wieder
einmal vor der entscheidung was sie sein
will eine zu unserem staat gehörende ihn
wie eine normale partei mit tragende
politische kraft oder eine anti system
partei die zu den etablierten
politischen kräften eine alternative
bietet und die sich anheischig macht
dieses system dessen probleme angeblich
nicht lösbar wären noch ein nicht näher
benanntes anderes zu ersetzen
dieser streit durchzieht die geschichte
der afd
im grunde seitdem sie in politische
bühne betreten hat bislang haben immer
jene den streit gewonnen die auf
radikalisierungen aus system ablehnung
setzen und jene deg afd
gemäss sozusagen ihrem gründungs etwas
zu einer liberal-konservativen
mitspieler partei aus gestalten wollten
sie haben die partei schrittweise
verlassen
ob diesmal der streit anders ausgeht der
notwendigkeit im übrigen das ist
abzuwarten die wesentliche veränderungen
zu früheren streit und dann ist das die
afd inzwischen vom bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird und
dass natürlich die politischen gegner
der afd das benutzen sozusagen
vernünftige leute davon abzuhalten sich
irgendwie mit dieser toxisch gewordenen
partei gemein zu machen
und wenn die afg es nicht schafft sich
hier als eine vernünftige auch für
öffentlich bedienstete die
mitgliedschaft nicht unerträglich machen
die partei aufzustellen
dann wird die partei in zukunft
insbesondere den westdeutschen ländern
kaum mehr tüchtige leute anziehen und
dann wird es mit ihr in den graben gehen
also sie muss sich entscheiden sagen
dass es klar ist in welche richtung so
geht es wie radikal ist ihrer meinung
nach die afd
wir haben in den letzten jahren ein
permanenter radikalisierung bhf die
erlebt in der der flügel eine immer
wachsende bedeutung gewonnen hat und in
den bisherigen partei streitigkeiten in
denen jeweils der flügel auch eine ganz
zentrale rolle spielte konnte sich immer
dieser flügel auch durchsetzen und er in
dieser ersten welle verließ eine lücke
henkel und ihre gefolgsleute die kfd in
der zweiten welle dann petri und und
ihre gefolgsleute die schon rechts
populistischen kurs hier vertreten haben
die die partei momentan geht das nicht
mehr um streit zwischen gemäßigten sie
sie selbst darstellen in der afg und und
radikalen kräften in der afd
die gemäßigten kräfte haben die afg
längst verlassen
es geht aber natürlich sehr wohl jetzt
um die frage wie reagiert man durch den
auf den äußeren druck der dadurch
entstanden ist dass das die gesamt
beobachtung der wörter fdj und hier
haben wir 22 positionen im
bundesvorstand letztlich wollten den
bisher die vergangenheit von kallwitz
natürlich herzlich egal war macht nun
eine komplette komplett wende angesichts
der drohenden gesamt beobachtung der afd
und das vor dem hintergrund der
anstehenden wahlkämpfe im westen länger
darf ich kurz nachfragen weil sie sagen
die gemäßigten kräfte haben die afg
längst verlassen ist herr pastörs wegen
ihren augen nicht gemäßigt gemäßigt ist
er ist ja ganz sicher nicht als gemäßigt
bürgerlich konservativ ist er ist ja
ganz sicher sicher nicht hat natürlich
eine ganz andere position nochmals
sorgen kallwitz es geht eine
rechtspopulistische richtung ausrichtung
bei ihm auch bei bayern leuten das ist
auch bei frauke petry beispielsweise mit
der marine le pen zusammengearbeitet hat
der der fall dass man aber natürlich
trotzdem deutlicher unterschied zu den
positionen die wirkung kallwitz
vertreten
pötke hat ja von der eigenen partei
gutachten über große nähe zum
nationalsozialismus
gutachten bekommen und das sind
natürlich noch immer etwas anderes als
das was der ski und petri vertreten da
passt das mit gemäßigter das nicht okay
er keine zeit sie sind würden nicht zu
den gemäßigten kräften sagen sie haben
heute im ard morgenmagazin gesagt die
mitglieder des ehemaligen flügels die
können eine wichtige rolle in der partei
spielen die können ein breites spektrum
abdecken dass wir die partei muss ein
breites spektrum abdecken und dazu
gehört die national konservative
positionen dazu welche rolle soll der
flügel spielen ja zunächst mal muss ich
ein teil ist natürlich widersprechen
wissen sie herr keil im gegensatz zu ihm
habe ich 41 jahre diesem land treu
gedient und das recht und die freiheit
des deutschen volkes tapfer verteidigt
und ich sehe mich schon als bürgerlich
und ich bin zutiefst bürgerlich ich weiß
nicht wo sie ihre informationen her
beziehen
und ich sehe auch einen herrn morgen und
viele andere in der partei als zutiefst
bürgerlich was ich damit sagen will ist
natürlich muss eine konservative partei
muss durchaus das spektrum von liberal
konservativ bis nationalkonservativ
abdecken
und man muss auch ein seriöses angebot
für national konservative strömungen
machen und ich betone ganz bewusst ein
seriöses angebot da müssen auch die
personen stimmen da müssen die
entsprechenden leute weil sein aber sie
haben aber der händler dort zum bei dem
appell der 100 haben sie im juli 2009 10
haben sie zum kyffhäuser treffen was
immer bio mitveranstaltet da haben sie
gewonnen spaltungstendenzen vorgeworfen
da haben sie gesagt dass sie da haben
sie sich kritisch sehr kritisch geäußert
gegenüber dem flieger und ich habe mich
kritisch gegenüber dem flügel geäußert
weil ich dieses premium und dieses
auftreten was da auf dem gewässer
treffen stattgefunden hat und auch die
reden die dort gehalten worden sind
zutiefst als etwas empfinde was was ich
einfach nicht befürworten kann in einer
partei wir sind eine demokratische
partei
und da haben solche dinge solche ja ich
sag mal solche auswüchse haben da nichts
verloren aber eher schwer haben gesagt
ja von einem hacker erwartet dass er
eine klare linien ja sie tut er das
ihrer meinung nach ich denke wir
brauchen eine brandmauer nach rechts ist
der morgen sehr schön gesagt und die
person
die offensichtlich bereit sind ich sag
mal diese brandmauer nicht undurchlässig
zu machen
die müssen sich jetzt klar werden
darüber gehören sie in die partei wollen
sie in der parteipolitik machen denn ich
stimme herrn betzel zu wir müssen als
partei müssen wir ein angebot für den
für die für das für die bürgerliche
wählerschaft machen uns weil die
konservative die die von der cdu
verlassen worden sind und wir haben das
ja auch wenn sie unser parteiprogramm
lesen dann ist das ein zutiefst
bürgerliches parteiprogramm und ich
denke es aber auch eine bürgerliche
partei und johanna eine bürgerliche
partei wie die cdu die cdu hat sich
immer weiter nach links verschoben
sonst würde es keine werte und juni in
der cdu gehen das muss man reden jetzt
über die fdm fragen halt eben inwieweit
gibt es eine brandmauer nach rechts frau
vieler wo sehen sie grenzt dass ich hier
eine unserer aufgaben die haben nur zu
ziehen das ist die frage wie beurteilen
sie ist wie sehr begrenzt die afd sich
von ganz rechts ab also erstmal finde
ich muss man sich angucken mit welchen
argumenten wird sich denn hier
abgegrenzt ich sehe da auch formale
argumente jetzt bei herrn kallwitz sagt
man ja er hat nicht angegeben dass er da
in der heimattreuen deutschen jugend war
er hat nicht angegeben dass er bei den
republikanern war aber keiner sagt ja
herr keilwitz ist ein rechtsextremist
das höre ich aus der fdp nicht sondern
da wird immer gesagt er hat seine seine
vergangenheit verschwiegen oder eben
diese bezüge von damals oder sie haben
jetzt gesagt damals sie haben angespielt
auf 2018 käfertreffen da wurde eben
dieses brimborium und handgemacht rosa
fahnen einzug seine treusten anhänger
haben abzeichen verliehen bekommen das
ist konnte man schon sagen fast ein
führerkult gewesen
sie sagen so ein problem finden sie
nicht gut aber das da kritisieren sie
eben das auftreten aber nicht die
inhalte die dort verbreitet wurden wir
schauen wir schon gleichzeitig hatten
wir im sommer millionen zum im sommer
2018 hatten wir eine massive
beschleunigung der radikalisierung
nochmal in der afg war sprach aargau
land
damals parteivorsitzender davon ein
ganzes system ein ganzer apparat müsse
weg nicht nur frau merkel und gegen
solche aussagen habe ich da keine
abgrenzung gesehen und insofern glaube
ich dass auch die abgrenzung die jetzt
passiert wo man sagt wir haben den
flügel aufgelöst und die haben ein
kalbitz rausgeworfen
dass diese abgrenzung eben auch vor
allem die angst vor dem
verfassungsschutz geschuldet waren
welche rolle spielt es darf die ard vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird
er spielt eine überaus große rolle denn
die beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz ist kreditiert ja
sozusagen sämtliche die wird ja nicht
beobachtet vom verkehrsverein ist sie
auch nicht teile davon oder von flügel
und die junge mutter vor und die junge
alternative und also wir schon wir
müssen schon klar bleiben in
niedersachsen werden sind teile der afg
vom verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem
eingestuft worden
der flügel okay jetzt wie herr fahrzeug
wieder und an dieser stelle reicht es ja
für den zweck des politischen kampfes
gegen die afg aussagen zu können und
irgendetwas macht der verfassungsschutz
mit denen er hält ein auge drauf auf
alle oder nur teile
das ganze macht der sozusagen jedem der
in der öffentlichkeit etwas gelten will
unmöglich sich irgendwie mit der hälfte
einzulassen und das ist natürlich ein
mittel im politischen kampf gegen die
afc east
und da scheint nun innerhalb der afg
einesteils die entschlossenheit gestärkt
zu haben die rechten und rechtsradikalen
in der partei entschlossener und mit
allen gerade noch gegebenen rechtlichen
möglichkeiten um ihren einfluss und um
ihre identifikation von außen im etat fd
zu bringen und das ganze stärkt dann
auch den kampf gegen die rechten in der
partei infolgedessen glaube ich dass
herr pastörs kay und haben heute so
weiter
nachgerade dankbar sein können über die
aktivitäten des
bundesverfassungsschutzes walters sind
schlechterdings unwiderlegbare argumente
für die schädlichkeit des verbleibens
von leuten in der afd
die in der öffentlichkeit den internet
die mit ab und zu sogar hinterhältige
äußerungen gegen ihre eigenen
parteikollegen alle
seriosität bemühungen jetzt ist haben
wir glaube ich eine kleine verzögerung
habe glaube ich mir gerade kleine
verzögerung sollen kurz zu herrn kalt
herr keil
was würden sie denn sagen wenn er passt
das gesagt es geht darum dass es eine
nationalkonservative politische kraft
gibt die rechts von der cdu steht geht
das und kann die afg so eine partei sein
das sieht das nicht sein kann also mit
mit henkel und luke stand ja zunächst
tatsächlich im bürgerlich konservativen
kurs mit mit rechtspopulistischen
einschlägen annina fd und dieser bei
dieser kurz war aber nicht
mehrheitsfähig dann letztlich in der in
der partei und auch petri die die stärke
die die verbindung zu anderen
rechtspopulistischen parteien fpö und
rassam play national in frankreich wird
er gesucht hat das war dem rechten
rechtsextremen teil der parteien nicht
weit genug nach rechts gehend und
insofern war war diese war diese waren
diese versuche zum scheitern verurteilt
wir haben gerade in den östlichen
bundesländern der parteibasis auch die
die natürlich auch mit getrieben hat in
diese diese richtung und deswegen haben
wir jetzt natürlich auch nur situation
der spaltung zwischen ostdeutschen und
westdeutschen landesverbänden
die wir ganz klar im auge haben müssen
in dem westdeutschen landesverbänden
spielt die drohende beobachtung der
gesamtpartei durch den verfassungsschutz
eine sehr große rolle wir haben hier
gerade bei personen die im öffentlichen
dienst verankert sind natürlich geradezu
angst bis hin zur panik das dass hier
tatsächlich diese einstufung erfolgt
während es in den ostdeutschen
landesverbänden eher eine trotz reaktion
auslöst und sagt hier ist ohnehin der
politik gegner wir können uns doch nicht
auf argumente des politischen gegners
einlassen und zugeständnisse machen das
wird wie das heute formuliert als verrat
empfunden etwas der sce die kfd ist im
osten sehr erfolgreich bei den letzten
landtagswahlen in brandenburg
brandenburg waren es 23 5% führungen
23,4 in sachsen 27,5 prozent
wie kommt es dass sie im osten so viel
erfolgreicher sind und was bedeutet das
jetzt für ihren richtungsstreit also ich
kann das nur für berlin auch wiederhole
ich war ja nun auch vier jahre
landesvorsitzender berlin wir haben auch
in ost berlin haben wir immer
hervorragende ergebnisse
wir haben wie marzahn hellersdorf haben
wir fast 30 prozent geholt wir haben
dort teilweise einzelergebnisse von über
30% wir haben in bestimmten stadtteilen
im osten von berlin haben wir 37 38
prozent also es hängt durchaus mit der
ich sag mal mit der geschichte der
beiden deutschen staaten zusammen im
westen ist man da offensichtlich viel
stärker an das alte parteiensystem
gefunden als im osten und im osten ist
durchaus auch eine gewisse bereitschaft
da eine neue partei zu wählen zu schauen
was die partei macht und zu sehen ob die
partei tatsächlich auch das erfüllt was
man sich vorstellt sie wissen früher war
sogar so gut wären die partei auch
früher was er so gewesen dass das im
osten die linkspartei besonders stark
war
jetzt ist die afg besonders stark im
osten also es gibt durchaus den drang
auch im osten dass man sagt wir wollen
über diese diese wahl entweder das der
der der konservativen afd wollen wir
politik mit beeinflussen
ich denke wir brauchen unsere politik
gar nicht zu ändern wir haben ein gutes
programm ein gutes grundsatzprogramm wir
haben ein bundestagswahlprogramm in dem
alles drin steht müsste der herr keil
ich vielleicht mal lesen wenn es noch
nicht getan hat das zeigt sehr deutlich
dass wir auf dem boden des grundgesetzes
stehen das zeigt sehr deutlich in welche
richtung wir wollen und ich muss noch
ein punkt ganz deutlich machen ich bin
seit zwei 2013 in dieser partei seit
märz 2013 höre ich dass die afd eine
rechte partei ist und sicherer die
analysiert selbst lücke wurde im
fernsehen angegriffen dass er sich
radikalisierte seiner
rechtspopulistischen rechts ist wir
haben gehört in braunschweig im letzten
jahr als der bundesvorstand gewählt
worden ist jetzt trifft die afg
endgültig nach rechts ich darf mal einen
sagen dieser bundesvorstand hat herrn
kalbitz die mitgliedschaft anerkannt hat
dem flügel aufgelöst hat herrn guido
rahn cdu und rausgeworfen hat eine frau
sayn-wittgenstein raus geworden und ein
herr apple hat auch ein
parteiausschlussverfahren
dh aber was bedeutet eine deutliche nein
das werden hier es wird hier
es wird hier auch eine schimäre
aufgebaut nach dem motto es wird auf 125
personen geschaut dann wird gesagt und
das ist die afg und die radikalisiert
sich und da sieht man nicht dass eben ja
warum 30.000 waren sie ganz normal
politik machen wollen bemerken sie denn
trotzdem dann dass der flügel ganz
wichtig ist für die partei das ist doch
ein widerspruch dass eine vernünftige
rolle haben wenn er ein seriöses angebot
macht und ich habe immer gesagt das
macht der flügel der flügel und solange
er auf dem boden der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung steht und
dass du gehst der ein teil ist er ein
teil dieser partei sagte er indes nicht
wer in diesem flügel nicht auf dem boden
der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung steht hat in dieser partei
nichts verloren
das habe ich lege sehr deutlich teile
des flügels nicht auf dem boden des
gastes sage ich ja auch es gibt
bestimmte personen die stehen nicht auf
dem boden des grundgesetzes und das gilt
es doch herauszufinden wer diese
personen sind und dann muss man
maßnahmen ergreifen da muss man den
deutlich machen leute wenn ihr
tatsächlich diese meinung vertreten wenn
ihr glaubt das ist nicht das was wir als
partei wollen dann müsst ihr euch eine
andere partei so hecker gehört nicht
dazu ihrer meinung nach also wissen sie
ich werde ja immer wieder gefragt ja was
ist denn kommt als nächster herr hüppe
dran oder was passiert jetzt wie sie
wenn wenn herr hackl eine hdj
mitgliedschaft verschwiegen hat oder ein
paar ski eine hdj mitgliedschaft
verschwiegen hat wird mit ihm genauso
umgegangen wie mit einem herrn kann
das ist nicht der einzige frau fiedler
wie wichtig was ist mit den anhängern
des flügels also wie sehr ist wenn man
der flügel sich formal auflöst sind er
dann trotzdem nicht alle menschen die
den flügeln
wir sind ja dann weg oder sie verändern
sich auf einmal wie sollte man damit
umgehen ja das ist eben genau der punkt
warum auch die auflösung des flügels
alleine erstmal gar nichts weiter
bewirkt also es ist natürlich ein signal
nach außen aber die leute die dem flügel
anhängen oder von ihm begeistert waren
die sind ja immer noch in der partei
und die gehen auch erstmal nicht weg und
das ist auch der grund warum aus
hochrangiger stelle aus dem
verfassungsschutz man hörte das ist eine
nebelkerze das ist eine schein auflösung
und so lange da nicht personelle
konsequenzen folgen ändert eigentlich
auch diese auflösung des flügels
letztendlich gar nichts und das dann
eine ost west frage auf was sie
besonders frau fiedler
das merken wir auch in den letzten buch
und dass etwas passiert weil sie mussten
ja noch was machen also in einer
stilvollen leuten ist um jeden preis die
gesamt beobachtung zu verhindern
das sehe ich auch aber gleichzeitig muss
man halt sagen hermann hat früher mit
dem flügel paktiert er war dreimal beim
käfertreffen er ist nach schnell oder
greifen polizisten geschlagen ja und
angegriffen also wir reden jetzt
vermuten ist nach schnellroda gereist
zentrum der neuen rechten in deutschland
erhalten hat mit dem flügel die liste
fürs europaparlament abgesprochen er ist
so hört man sogar mit stimmen des
flügels jetzt nochmal zum partei also er
hat in der vergangenheit mit dem flügel
paktiert aber man hat eine veränderung
bei ihm gesehen als es losging dass der
verfassungsschutz gesagt wir nehmen
jetzt die auf die genauer unter die lupe
da ist er reingegangen das hat man
deutlich gesehen ist auf dem
landesparteitag in baden württemberg
gegangen in heidenheim und hat gesagt
jetzt krieg ich gerade nicht zusammen
also für quasi menschenverachtende
rhetorik ist hier bei uns in der partei
keinen platz er hat gesagt diese
verrückten radikalen
die wollen wir hier nicht haben also
dass man hat aber gesehen diese
veränderung kam mit der bedrohung durch
den verfassungsschutz
ihr fazit wer ist denn im moment ihrer
meinung nach der mächtigste mann unter
den mächtigsten frauen der kfd nämlich
dass nur genau wüsste denn von außen
scheint es so dass sie politisches sehr
schnell mit persönlichen vermengt und
dass sie dann auch tagesaktuelle
bündnisse sich zusammenfinden
aber das er es geschafft hat den
brandenburgischen ehemaligen
fraktionsvorsitzenden aus der partei zu
bekommen freilich mit einer knappen
mehrheit dass es der afg gelungen ist
sich von leuten wie es an wittenstein
usw zu trennen
das zeigt schon dass die stärkeren
bataillone in der bundesweiten partei
wohl nicht auf seiten der
rechtsradikalen stehen die meisten
wesentlich stärker sind als im westen
wie der kampf tatsächlich ausgeht das
wird man tatsächlich abwarten müssen
aber im moment haben jene die die
rechtsradikale in der afd
klein kriegen wollen die gewichtigeren
sturmgeschütz auf ihrer seite und da
hilft eben das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz ganz gewaltig beim
innerparteilichen kampf her kennt wen
würden sie dann gesehen als den
mächtigsten mann oder die mächtigste
frau in dieser partei
also ich kann herrn ein paar cent nur
fundamental widersprechen sich die
kräfteverhältnisse ganz anders die die
starke eine schlüsselrolle in den
vergangenen konflikten hat bauland
gespielt man muss auch sagen diesmal bei
diesem aktuellen konflikt war ja die
situation gegeben er hat sich vehement
dagegen ausgesprochen auch im
bundesvorstand aber hatte keine stimme
und er hat er hat eine integrierende
funktion in der partei gehabt und bei
die banken beiden vergangenen konflikte
gegen hängte locker und gegen petri sind
entscheidend auch deswegen gegen diese
ausgegangen weil genannt hier nicht zu
unterschätzen ist als strippenzieher
hinter den kulissen in der partei der
die flügel und die anderen in der partei
praktisch eine brücke brücke bildet
petri hat er auch immer nicht direkt mit
mit öko und kalbitz paktiert in sondern
immer über über über gaul an bauland ist
ja was tatsächlich einer der
mitinitiatoren der apo der klärung
es wird immer vergessen dass neben heiko
mallwitz auch gern an die spitze des
flügels bildet das heißt wir haben seit
langer zeit die situation dass der
flügel an der spitze der partei stand
und gaunern spielt jetzt auch wieder
eine schlüsselrolle
auch aufgrund seines hohen alters sollte
man diese eben nicht nicht untere
unterschätzen
gegen ihn und er ist hat sich massiv
gegen diesen diesen ausschluss von von
karl bezirk positioniert an seiner seite
stehen europa unter und weide
das heißt wenn wir uns die vier
zentralen personen in der datei an
anschauen haben sich drei massiv gegen
den außer gegen die annullierung der
mitgliedschaft ausgesprochen von diesen
vier ist momentan derjenige der auf
allein auf dem dem posten steht die
andere seite hat er hat den vorteil dass
sie mit weidl auch eine brücke in die
anderen partei teile hinein noch noch
hat das heißt weidl gehört ja selbst
über geld selbst nicht zum flügel hat
auch nicht die sozial patriot ihre diese
diese rentenpolitik die die vielen im
westen grad doch bitter aufstößt und der
wirtschaftsliberale teil der afg wird
natürlich durch weil dann auch
entsprechend angesprochen hat hier eine
ähnliche position mit die meisten und
leinwand ist meines erachtens schon eine
deutliche deutlichen vorteil für dieses
lag ja herr pastörs gw alleine steht
herr meuten da in ihrer partei entsteht
überhaupt nicht alleine da sondern ich
weiß aus vielen gesprächen und auf
vielen e-mails ich kriege dass der kurs
von vermögen von einem großteil der
partei mitgetragen wird und es gibt ja
eine neue umfrage von rtl und n tv
wonach die wähler 62 prozent der fdp
wähler sagen jawoll der kurs von morgen
ist der richtige und nur 22 prozent
sagen nein der kurs von herrn hüppe ist
er richtig
also das sind die mehrheiten ist ja auch
dass diese beiden nur noch die mehrheit
sichern dass im bundesvorstand haben sie
im prinzip sieben personen die den
ausschluss von herrn kalbitz bescheinigt
haben bzw nichtmitgliedschaft
bescheinigt haben
helgoland hat ja keine stimme und selbst
daher keilwitz wenn damit gestimmt hätte
wäre 7 zu 6 ausgegangen muss man ist
mathematik und der block morgen hat im
bundesvorstand eine klare mehrheit
und es könnte sogar so sein dass die
mehrheit jetzt nachdem herr kalbitz
draußen ist sogar noch komfortabler wird
und ich weiß auch dass dieser vorstand
ein sehr seriöser vorstand ist der
bericht nichts übers knie und der sagt
wir müssen jetzt unbedingt eine
säuberung der partei durchführen sondern
es geht darum dass man sieht wo sind
verfehlungen wo muss man verfehlung
nachgehen wo müssen verfehlungen
geahndet werden
denn wir dürfen ja einzig vergessen eine
partei kann ja nicht willkürlich handeln
sie ist ja an das parteiengesetz
gebunden habe und es werden uns immer
auch vorgeworfen warum schließen sie den
herrn ich will immer vorlesen was der
ganz kurz nur wenn ich darf einem
mitglied kann nur aus der partei
ausgeschlossen werden wenn es
vorsätzlich gegen die satzung verstößt
vorsätzlich erheblich gegen grundsätze
der oder ordnung der partei verstoßen
und damit schweren schaden zufügt das
bedeutet dass müssen die inhalte
ausschlussverfahren in ein
parteiausschluss das begründen er das
der fall ist es war noch nicht schwer
das ist die kritik an ihm die frage ist
ja da können ja sagen sie würden das
gerne haben sie können ja die kritik
äußern
also dass der punkt ist doch es gab ein
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen herne
das parteilose ausschuss erfahrung ist
eingestellt worden
damit sind alle die dinge die in diesem
parteiausschlussverfahren behandelt
worden sind sind hinfällig weil sie
bereits unterlagen direkt an sie etwas
gefunden sie ist besser für die afg und
die zukunft dieser partei wenn herr
höcker nicht mehr mitglied dieser partei
wäre ich finde es gut wenn hacker sich
auf seine rolle endlich konzentrieren
würde und
einer der maurer der brandmauer gegen
rechts wäre ich würde einfach der partei
heute kann eine wichtige rolle spielen
das habe ich das wiederhole ich sehr
sehr lange schon wenn er es endlich wenn
er endlich seine aufgabe wahrnimmt und
die parteien nach rechts abdichtet und
das erwarte ich von ihm zumindest macht
er das nicht so eindeutig klar okay
geschrieben in dem er sich für einen
relegationsplatz ausspricht bei denen
sich auch menschliche herten nicht
vermeiden lassen also dass und das war
nach dem ende des
parteiausschlussverfahrens gegen ihn
also ich wenn ich sowas lese da glaube
ich nicht an eine brandmauer ich bin
aber habe es ist es ist zumindestens ist
es nicht nur ein angebot an herrn ecke
sondern ich erwarte dass eigentlich von
einem parteimitglied der ja ich sag mal
auch jemand ist der verantwortung für
diese partei trägt der verantwortung für
seine landespartei für sein
landesverband trägt und da erwarte ich
auch dass er in der programmatik der afg
handelt ok kommen wir mal zu den themen
die die afg besetzung sollte sie ist
groß geworden als kritiker also in der
euro-krise dann halt eben die frage nach
dem die in der migrationspolitik
jetzt gibt es die frage wie verhält man
sich angesichts corona herr patzelt was
ist denn jetzt eigentlich das wichtigste
thema auf das die afd moment setzen
sollte oder gerade auch setzt im moment
gibt es kein aktuelles thema auf welches
die afg mit irgendwelcher aussicht auf
popularitäts gewinne setzen könnte denn
in der korona bekämpft politik ist die
regierung tatkräftig gewesen ihre
umfragewerte sind steil nach oben
gegangen
und an der stelle zu kritisieren bringt
eine lediglich in die reihen derer die
behaupten das virus sei ohnehin ganz
sogar ungefährlich oder irgendwelche
sinistren mannschaften im hintergrund
würden hier eine krise vorspiel die
tatsächlichen mobilisierungs um
gewinnerthemen der afg sind diejenigen
um die herum die auf die ko's geworden
ist das ist die eurozone mit der
riskanten finanzierungspolitik die unter
dem namen core
der bons demnächst auf die europäische
union auf deutschland hat finanziell zu
kommen werden das ist die fdp wieder
weil ein neues thema finden wenn es um
diese corona bonns ging ja die korona
booms schon knüpfen ja die korona krise
mit dem klassischen thema wie geht es in
der eurozone weiter ist es eine schulden
vergemeinschaftung union gilt weiterhin
die versprechung dass man nicht für die
schulden eines anderen staates haften
würden
das andere thema ist die rolle der
europäischen union die rolle der staaten
innerhalb der europäischen union
gerade weil deutschland in der zweiten
jahreshälfte die präsidentschaft
übernehmen wird und dass die zeit ist
der auf deutschland erheblicher druck
ausgeübt werden wird die spendierhosen
anzuziehen wird dass hier ein ganz
vorzüglich als mobilisierungsthema für
die afg sein und das dritte thema ist
die migration denn die folgen der
migration sind da in keiner weise
bewältigt sobald das überwölbende
coroner thema weg ist und das klima
thema vielleicht nicht wieder ganz so
hoch gefahren wird wie vor der krise
wären die ganzen anschluss probleme der
migration zurück und da wird die afg
auch pumpen können freilich dadurch
zunichte gemacht dass in der ard im
internet unter den funktionsträgern
immer wieder leute auftreten welche
seriöse politische positionen der afg
unglaubwürdig machen weil man es diese
position dann schnell als ausbund von
rassismus und nationalsozialistischer
gesinnung ausgeben kann
folglich muss die afd wenn sie je wieder
punkten will
genau dieses innerparteiliche problem
lösen okay da music klare position
beziehen sagen sie herr keines welches
thema ist das wichtigste für die afd um
eine starke partei zu sein
dazu werden sie in dem moment sinken die
umfragewerte ja etwas die union dagegen
nimmt stark zu
also wo es so ein punkt wo sie sagen das
ist eigentlich ein typisches afd thema
und das ist ein thema womit sie auch
weiter wirklich viele wähler finden kann
7 stark auf die angebotsseite ich würde
dir die nachfrageseite als ein
entscheidender punkt
ansehen wenn sich die korona krise vor
ford setzt haben wir bestimmte probe
folgeprobleme sie haben nur einen punkt
ab az schon angesprochen mit dem corona
bonds der für die mobilisierung der afg
ein einfallstor bieten kann
dann werden wir eine langanhaltende also
eine länger anhaltende rezession
wahrscheinlich durch durchleben mit mit
stark wachsenden arbeitslosenzahlen
all das ist ist also futter natürlich
für eine sehr für eine extrem weit
rechts stehende partei und den wir
insofern ist die frage ob sich das
angebot der ard momentan sehr groß
ändern muss im moment natürlich sieht es
so aus als sei es einen absoluten
absoluten krise und es hängt natürlich
jetzt auch viel von ihrem eigenen
verhalten mit der im zuge dieses dieses
richtungskampf das zusammen allerdings
ist für die für die weitere entwicklung
der afg entscheidender wie die
gesamtsituation der bundesrepublik sich
entwickelt die frage ist aber auch man
kann auch mal die frage stellen nach der
glaubwürdigkeit zum beispiel beim thema
corona frau fiedler da haben wir am
anfang alles weil gehört die gesagt man
muss man viel härteren kurs fahren da
muss hätten die bundesregierung hätte
schneller reagieren sollen jetzt dagegen
gibt es viel kritik an den maßnahmen und
wird wird auf die grundrechte geschaut
und sagt wir müssen das lockern
also wo sehen sie da die afg in der
position gerade in der korona krise die
afg hat sich wie sie es gerade auch
schon beschrieben haben so ein bisschen
flexibel gezeigt erst mal am anfang auch
der korona krise und da ihre positionen
aus ein bisschen geändert
ich glaube es war für die partei am
anfang nicht ganz klar was jetzt hier
die typische auf die position wäre die
man besetzen könnte oder wie man hier
quasi auch protestpartei sein kann denn
am anfang hat auch herr gauland gesagt
zusammenstehen ist jetzt irgendwie erste
bürgerpflicht
das war schon bemerkenswert und jetzt
finde ich sehr spannend dass man sehen
kann dass die fdp schon versucht auch
auf diesen zug der korona proteste so
ein bisschen aufzuspringen nicht überall
man hat gesehen es gab ein hfg demo in
stuttgart im osten gibt es sehr viele
corona proteste corona demos die von der
afg organisiert wurden auch zb hyballa
der parteichef ist bei diesen protesten
aufgetreten
und ja insofern hat sich die fdp in eine
anti lockdown partei verwandelt und
versucht eben von den protesten zu
protestieren aber das birgt eben auch
die gefahr dass man dann auf diesen
protesten auf diesen demos leute hat die
massiv verschwörungstheorien anhängen wo
ist da ihre position hatte pastörs kiwi
inwieweit ist die sind diese corona
proteste ein ausdruck von dem was sie
als partei da richtig finden
also was wir zu beginn gemacht haben wir
haben natürlich alle maßnahmen die
notwendig waren und die wir als
erforderlich angesehen haben haben wir
unterstützt auch im abgeordnetenhaus
haben wir das getan weil wir gesagt
haben
natürlich müssen wir an das wohl der
bürger ding natürlich müssen wir an die
gesundheit der bevölkerung denken
nur wenn sie sich die ganzen maßnahmen
anschauen dann stellen sie sehr schnell
fest dass teilweise überzogen worden ist
dass auf der anderen seite auch
grundrechte eingeschränkt worden sind
unnötiger weise eingeschränkt worden
sind und dass vor allen dingen viele
maßen oder sich auf maßnahmen
widersprechen ja es gab von anfang an
gab es beispielsweise keine auflagen für
baumärkte
man konnte weiterhin den baumarkt
einkaufen aber man konnte nicht
beispielsweise in ein möbelhaus gehen
oder man konnte in andere bereiche gehen
also haben sich manche maßnahmen haben
sich widersprochen und da hat sich
natürlich auch unmut aufgestaut auch bei
der bevölkerung die gesagt aber auch
bundes einer volleyball märkte
geschlossen habe ja ist ja es nun gut
das muss man auch sehen und auch wenn
man heute anschaut dass die maßnahmen
sind nicht logischen sich ja auf der
einen seite braucht man etwas auf der
anderen seite darf man es nicht obwohl
es im prinzip die gleiche situation ist
und wo ich das sehe heute wir müssen
schon ein wichtiges augenmerk auf unsere
grundrechte legen und wenn die
grundrechte eingeschränkt werden würde
werden oder wie in berlin dass
beispielsweise der senat ich sag mal
über das parlament hinweg bestimmte
entscheidungen trifft um das parlament
zu beteiligen
dann haben wir ein problem in einer
parlamentarischen demokratie ja wir
waren sie aber auch die menschen die da
protestieren weil auch da gibt es ja
sehr extrem entwickelt die
verschwörungstheoretiker gibt sehr
extreme gruppen die dort protestieren
wie sehr ist das welches kriterien nach
welchen kriterien protestieren sie da
muss ich muss ich sagen da wo wir
protestieren da geht es im prinzip um
die einschränkung der grundrechte
ja es geht nicht darum nach dem motto
alles sofort aufheben lockt dann
aufheben sondern es geht da drüben herrn
ramelow da folgen das finden sie richtig
wie der jetzt sagt von dem krisenmodus
in den regel modus und jajaja in berlin
haben wir das sehr sehr deutlich gemacht
wir haben gesagt wir müssen jetzt wieder
nach vorne schauen
denn es wurde auch hier angesprochen von
von herrn betzel und auch von von herrn
kind das im prinzip wir die auswirkungen
der korona krise vor uns haben wir haben
wir werden einer rezession haben wir
werden erhebliche verwerfungen und ich
gehe noch einen schritt weiter wir
werden verteilungskämpfe haben in der
zukunft und da wird da wird jetzt
sicherlich verteilungskämpfe geben
zwischen denjenigen die noch einen job
an denen die keinen job mehr haben und
möglicherweise auch zwischen den
migranten die herkommen also es wird es
wird hier ich glaube wenn wir das nicht
klug machen und richtig machen werden
wir großen aufruhr in deutschland
bekommen und deshalb geht es kommt auch
darauf an auch in dieser situation muss
man als partei muss man nach vorne
schauen und man muss sagen jawohl wie
können wir das verhindern
okay aber dafür müssen sie erstmal auch
ihren internen streit regeln damit sie
da wie eine ruhe haben in der partei es
wird passieren in das wird passieren
sagen sie wer wird denn da dann
sozusagen gewinnen in dem fall
es gibt keine gewinner sondern ich denke
es geht darum dass wir die partei so
aufstellen dass die partei für breite
von geschichten oder beide
wählerschichten welt wird dass wir
wieder an werte heran kommen ich habe
immer gesagt die wir wir gewinnen keine
wir gewinnen keine wähler am rechten
rand sondern wir gewinnen wähler in der
mitte also wahr werden in der mitte
gewonnen
auf dem muss muss sich so aufstellen
dass sie eine bürgerlich konservative
partei ist dass sie genau in das vakuum
vorstößt in das ja die werte union
rollenbilder und wo die zehn mal weg
gegangen
herr patzelt gibt es eine möglichkeit wo
sie sagen da kann die afg
koalitionsfähig werden für die cdu zum
beispiel auch wir sollten jetzt nicht im
jahr 2030 sprechen
davor ist es für jeden cdu-politiker ein
akt des politischen selbstmordes
überhaupt nur die schüler cfd hinaus zu
strecken
aber das ist strategisch von nicht klar
was zu tun ist die cdu hat für die afg
im politischen spektrum platz gemacht
weil sie die cdu darauf verzichtet hat
bis zu berichten nach
alles was halbwegs politisch bis drei
zählen kann in sich selbst stimmt diese
große volkspartei zu integrieren
in dieser repräsentations glückes lücke
hat sich die afg festgesetzt wir sind
auch deswegen weil von anfang an gesagt
wurde im grunde ist der look und
rechtsextrem ist unglaublich viele
rechtsradikale und rechtsextremisten zu
geströmt sie haben das gesicht der
partei und jenen politischen konflikt
erzeugt er jetzt in der top ten schaffen
diesen konflikt zu lasten der radikalen
zu entscheiden sich also als eine
tatsächlich seriös partei aufzustellen
und sollte die cdu weiterhin darauf
verzichten
zum rechten rand integrieren zu wollen
dann kann die afg sich getrost
zurücklehnen denn dann arbeitet das
schwarz grüne projekt für die afg und
herpa zeta wir in der realität von union
sind und sehen wollen ja dass die cdu
wieder konservativer wird und weder von
den alfa der afg zurückholen wenn die
cdu aber eben nicht konservativer wird
und schwarz-grün weiterverfolgt wäre das
um die afg sich nicht weiter
radikalisiert wäre das dann für sie der
moment auch zur afg zu gehen ich glaube
das ist eine völlige idiotische frage
mit verlaub gesagt die cdu ist meine
politische heimat meine politische
familie und bloß weil manche leute aus
frechen gründen auch immer
wahrscheinlicher rufmord an gibt zu
betreiben mit darunter stellen ich sei
ein verborgener als tele und meine
größte sehnsucht wäre es irgendwann mit
der cdu in der ard auf zu
wird diese rum sind dadurch nicht
richtiger klargestellt dass meine eigene
partei sich selbst um die chancen auf 50
prozent gebracht hat durch im kurs und
nach dem ende der sendung sind bleiben
aber in dem moment steht die cdu ja bei
knapp 40 prozent in den umfragen
da ist ja wirklich sehr nach rom
gegangen sind
die leute sind am ende der sendung das
ist etwas schwierig eigentlich wollte
ich sie auch noch ganz so weit kommen
dass ein keil ist aber das kriegen wir
jetzt nicht mehr hin zu wenig zeit aber
vielen dank für die diskussion das war
die phoenix runde in dieser woche guten
abend bei uns im programm
tschüss
[Musik]